what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have the team behind talk
to me here right now I'm obsessed with
your movie I love the midnight lineup in
general your concept I can't get out of
my head very well done well thank you
thank you thank you so much that's
awesome I don't know if you guys have
noticed but Miranda Otto is next to me
it's a pretty big that's Miranda
everyone and we're here we're excited to
be actually my mums yeah what are you
are you still a character
drag him
oh very important elements of the movie
I promise you uh for my directing do I
have to give these honors to you I know
about talk to me anybody who sees it at
Sundance will know and never forget
about this movie our audience does not
know what the film is about just yet can
you give me a brief synopsis of the
movie talk to me is about kids that use
demonic possession to get high
that is our that's a pretty good
description
it's incredibly accurate short and sweet
I love it for the two of you getting a
first feature off the ground is pretty
much a miracle so when you jump into
this what did you think was the first
step to making that happen and now
having gone through it would you
recommend that step to another filmmaker
out there or did you find something more
effective along the way yeah the best
first step is to find uh good producers
and that was uh the first step was I'm
reaching out and contacting Causeway we
could not believe they responded it was
like yeah like what yeah like Jose
responded and that was the big first
step and they they like guided us and
let us know how to you know because I'd
already reached out to some studios and
I said I've got a script and they're
like this is not how you approach people
and I was like oh so we have the fire
yeah so we got yeah got told off by the
studio but then yeah we figured out how
to do it we got there via producers and
managers what if you don't have a
producer a manager Danny it seems very
well no we didn't have a manager at that
point yes well yeah uh I think that to
get a film off the ground is you have to
you could have a proof of concept or a
short film or any sort of you just need
to prove that you can direct I don't
know we definitely didn't prove we could
direct I don't know why they gave us the
movie but oh please wait correct me if
I'm wrong on any of this you just
brought up Studios and I think I read
this somewhere that you did have some
interest from Studios but you decided to
make this movie independently which can
be a very scary decision to make so can
you walk us through that thought process
uh yeah I guess that we were starting to
develop it with them and they was trying
to sort of steer it towards a more
conventional route where there was a lot
of Exploration with our main horror item
our main horror prop and I just wanted
the kids and the characters to be out of
their depths and not know what they were
in you know what they were in oh God I
screwed up that question
yeah I watched the kids to be additives
and now understand what I really can't
answer this question
yeah we've got no sleep none of us have
we're on the same level this is
literally also creative control is very
important to us and that's something
that with a studio you get more money
uh you know up front but that that
control can get taken away from you and
that's scary and we knew that with
Causeway who we did it with that we'd be
safe and they would protect they put the
film first over everything yeah and then
freedom of cast as well not to have to
go for a this is like we wanted to find
like realistic these are all a-listers
what are you talking about
at the time yeah so it was about trying
to have the freedom to cast whoever we
wanted and um yeah take the script where
we wanted and just have the freedom so
what is the value of that money if you
don't have the creative freedom to do
what you want yes that's right yes yes
yes so for everyone in the cast here I
wrote a whole lot in the Press know it's
about how important authenticity was to
these characters so can you each tell me
something that's purely your own about
your character something that wasn't on
the page but you wanted to be in them on
screen
an [__]
yeah that was my yeah but like a one
that you wanna maybe have a little crush
on like you want to be their best friend
but they're going to be they're not
gonna be very nice to you
yeah
Zoe bought his [__] nature to sit
it's very authentic
not to set to the roles
who wants to jump in next uh I don't
know like there's a lot on the page I
have to say like I thought this group
was so well written but um I guess the
main thing that I really loved about the
character was the idea that like she was
she was kind of on it with them like she
was she was tricky and she she put them
through their paces and stuff but she
she kind of knows stuff's going on and I
thought that was fun to play yeah and
that you'd want to hang out with Sue
more than Jade because she's definitely
the cool mom a very aware mother but
sometimes in the wrong Mark but you know
she's included she's glued in
Sophie um yes mayor is like so awkward
and I think that I'm quite awkward as a
person so I'd say that's quite authentic
to uh to my personality and that's what
I brought to the character uh yeah if
you're not a little awkward you're
probably boring so better off
that's the excuse I use at least all
right Joe last up
um well I think like my relationship
with like my sister in the film and then
Mia and like just with everyone like I
don't know like with my sister I was I
could just easily use my real sister as
a substitute for Jade and Alex wasn't
here at the moment was great in the film
and yeah no it just felt really real and
I know if Riley's a bit of a loner and I
guess I'm a bit of a loner too so yeah
no in a good way in a good way
[Music]
yeah it's a cool owner a lone wolf
Miranda I'm coming back your way I've
been a big fan of your work for a long
long time and we have a new Ensemble
that if folks out there don't know their
names already they will soon even with
all your experience being on this set is
there anything you saw one of the
younger cast members do that made you go
like damn if only I could go back in
time and tell myself to give that a shot
when I was first starting out I was
thinking like damn about everybody last
night when I was watching the film I
just thought everyone did such
spectacular work
um
God I go back and tell myself I don't
know I was just really Blown Away by
everyone's performances and you know how
much Denny and Michael had worked with
them beforehand I was only there for
like five days shooting or something so
I just came in and did my little bit but
these guys rehearsed for ages together
and really worked on their characters
and yeah I just thought they had
it it is such a great sense for
authenticity and that that really comes
from Danny and Michael and the way they
work and they're you know they've got a
good [__] meter they they know when
it's when it's not real I feel like a
lot of films out there don't have the
luxury especially when they're
independently made to have rehearsal
time so can you guys tell me something
that you discovered about the story or
character during that rehearsal period
that proved pivotal yeah there was just
days where we had to get 10 minute
scenes in two days so we had to get into
the space and block it out because
otherwise we just wouldn't have been
able to execute it and luckily our
producer Sam was able to make the time
in pre-production we had a very small
pre-production but uh she made sort of
prioritize the the rehearsals and it was
yeah it was amazing to be able to go
into the space block it out and work
through the actors and find if there's
any lines or beats that just weren't
working for them so it was like it was a
group process to go through those rooms
and find out how how to how to position
people it was like yeah a really
collaborative effort it was yeah so yeah
well we did it ourselves as well in the
space
like shitty little rehearsals
yeah we did like pre-shoots and I think
performance was pretty good Sophie it
was really good yeah that was really
good as the dog
but I also love how you guys all do all
the curveball lines and stuff every time
we'd be doing takes they'd do like a
curb or kind of take where they'd tell
you to come in and say something
different to try and throw people off
and see if you can get an interesting
reaction yeah yeah like keeping uh the
actors on their toes like if you're the
seniors let them into the door what
happens if you don't yeah
and you get cool reactions genuine
reactions yeah and I think it keeps you
it keeps it fresh and we definitely did
that to Zoe quite a bit so can you can
you pinpoint a moment when they did that
to you and it really helped yeah
somebody said something pretty rude to
me in a good way I got a good reaction
but I think also like the way we shot it
which is what I love it was so fast and
loose like yeah the boys just kind of if
we felt on the day like there was
something else we could say the boys
were like yeah go you know so it meant
that
yeah it made for it was never boring and
I don't think we actually ever did
anything remotely similar twice
I follow up on that anyone can jump in
on this can you give me an example of a
scene when you did two like drastically
different takes like the most polar
opposite ones possible and you had to
choose between those two oh oh my gosh
there's one oh it probably isn't the
best example because we have to end up
removing the scene uh not because it was
a bad scene but because uh part of the
process yeah part of the process finding
the Rhythm uh there was a character who
no see this one's pointless isn't it no
not this one no no no no no no no no no
no no I've got one Max and Mia the the
Mom sorry the dad and Sophie uh Sophie
is that this is a scene that also got
caught for for reasons but amazing
performances there was one where we had
Sophie having the power in the scene
attacking the dad you know yelling at
the dad and and kind of putting him in
his place uh and he and we had him not
you know be powerful in that moment it
was Sophie but there was one take we did
it like four times and then one where we
said you snap back at her after she says
this line and he did and he did and I
think he had this aggression kind of you
know creeping up money he went boom he's
like no you're like you know kind of as
a parent to stop and it was shocking to
you want to say everyone no one knew
even the crew everyone's like okay we're
getting told off as well yeah yeah so
that was a really cool thing to see and
like that genuine reaction and
variations as well like when you're
trying to get the nurse like playing
different variations yeah yeah Miranda
did some takes to scare everyone as well
there are some kind ones and some very
unkind ones this is what physical media
is for we need physical media so we get
all of these deleted scenes
I am absolutely obsessed with lore and
movie Bibles and things like that so I
need to know did the two of you develop
like every little detail about like the
hand where it really did come from what
it's capable of any powers that we maybe
don't see in the film but you considered
what can you tell us about that yeah
you've been down to the to the writing
on the hand there's a law and a story in
a deep mythology G even the spirits that
are connecting with the uh every
character's emotions like everything's
really thought out and put through and
the mythology hopefully saying we can
expand on if we were able to do a sequel
uh yeah but yeah we want the characters
to be out of the depths we didn't
explore it that much we sort of hinted
at it with the characters but yes
everything's ironed out and there's a
whole big Bible it's called the
mythology Bible so we've got that yeah
it's a big prologue yeah
it's a trilogy
I I've said this a number of times today
we manifest things at this table so if
you say it we're going to speak it into
existence
[Laughter]
and two million dollars at the box
office
come on collider two million we make
everything happen
um was it always a hand and was the
phrase always talk to me or did you ever
consider anything else uh to begin with
it literally just was a board and then
it was it just uh yeah it came through
the very yeah all the drafts and then
finding in the films about the
connections between people real ones and
forced ones and yeah it's uh hands are a
very big Motif in the film so it just
felt really fitting and real and um yeah
Mir is rejecting the genuine connections
and I'm not gonna say anymore
there's a bunch of things on my list and
I'm like should I push it this far or
should I not so if I'm going to give
this one to you and maybe to only you
can you give us a do and a don't when
you're playing possessed
you do it exceptionally well
oh
I feel like
I feel like you need to like
Rhythm I think rhythm's really important
like shifting of Rhythm
um
and don't
oh I don't know if there are don'ts I
think the whole point of being possessed
is that you can do whatever you want and
go as far as you want and the further
you go the kind of better
that's probably the right answer I feel
like don't be embarrassed don't be
ashamed
yeah there was one the Montage there's a
montage sequence and we had all the
actors doing lots of different spirits
and things like that we had the main
ones we wanted to hit for particular
reasons but then also some other stuff
that we played around with which is a
lot of fun and like as all your your
position is amazing amazing and what you
see in behind the scenes it's 10 out of
10.
speaking of not being afraid not being
embarrassed for the cast here can you
give me an example a non-spoiler example
of a Time on set when something
intimidated you you were afraid to do it
but because of the environment that your
co-cast and your directors create it on
set you had the ability to go there with
it I think I cannot
um well Danny Michael approached me
about like doing stunts and I was like
it was like interesting and I was like
oh like do I do it like what am I going
to mess it up and then like would any
Market just spoke to me about it and
like I mean I didn't want to be like
them no I'm not going to do it you know
what I mean so I was just I don't know
supportive and then everyone like
everyone because you've got like all
these different people on set that help
you make feel safe and then like Michael
would do like the stunt like stunts with
me he's like oh I can do it then smashes
his head I'm like okay then I'll do it
and then it's like yeah but um I mean he
does stunts all the time he runs in
glass walls and everything so I mean if
I can so I can like do something then
yeah start flip on the table
yeah Joe was very very yeah he had a lot
of physical scenes and he did all his
own stunts and it was yeah incredible
and Sophie had some pretty intimidating
scenes and yes Sophie Sophie went there
and and pushed herself and they was like
yeah there's a scene when she sort of
punishing herself a little bit and she
committed and was yeah it was very very
full-on on set yeah you are yeah you
were so committed I do feel like we all
kind of followed soph's lead in that way
like I was [__] scared when I read the
scripts and I was like oh man this is
going to be so embarrassing you know as
an actor you're like ah
um and then I think like because I my
first day on set was your first
possession and I think you just like set
the tone and everyone was like okay like
that's where we're going and I think
like we kind of needed Soph to commit
and then everyone kind of saw what they
needed to match and I think that's how
we all got up there you know thank you
it's true you set the tone I get it kind
of some questions just for fun here
everyone can feel free to jump in on
these let's say you find an embalmed
hand that gives you the ability to
contact spirits who in your life is the
first person you go and run and tell
about it and they actually believe you
when you tell them oh my gosh Michael
that makes sense
I definitely I definitely wouldn't
believe him though yeah no I found this
oh shut up
who else has someone
um like probably my sister because she's
a bit older than me she's like 25 so
it's like I just tell her everything so
probably my sister actually no she
wouldn't believe me
my therapist
I would contact Miranda Otto and tell
her about it
I'm just saying any excuse to be able to
call Miranda
[Laughter]
the hand which which he dare to do it
I
from an actor's point of view I would
like that she would dare to do it like I
would like to do it
um but you know like Sue's pretty canny
like she's she's pretty pragmatic so
whether she would I don't know but it'd
be fun to force a situation where she
did like it would be fun to play like
everyone wants to like lose their [__] a
bit you know
question marks well it's been said at
the table
you know what we do here you know what
this is secret water that makes
everything happens
two more fun questions of everyone in
this cast who would you think would be
the very first one to actually step up
and be willing to use the hand in real
life Chris Chris
ran away from the interview about Chris
Chris get in here
would you not sir do the hand first out
of all of us
do the hand now yeah
yeah I'll give it a hand
oh I should have you couldn't go now we
said last night
we said last night in the Q a we've got
all the hands here there's like I don't
know a bunch of them and we've just
hidden them people have just hidden them
throughout our lodge
um and in different places so like I
went to doorway the other day and the
toilet paper was just on the hands
um they're just yesterday about the
house it's pretty Camp there's a big
moose head in the living room and our
behind the scenes guy climbed off and
just pop pop it on top yeah that's why
we didn't answer them by themselves and
actually some of them are actually
missing so we should find those hands oh
no that's why we wouldn't bring a hand
here but they're in impossible places to
reach right now yeah it was funny at
first but now we're doing another hand
here yeah sorry I I would be tempted and
then deep down I know I would do it
can't help it okay I like these Concepts
um I have to let you go soon I did want
to end on one unrelated question because
Zoe I'm very excited for what's around
the corner for you right now it is a big
deal you should be very proud and I know
there's a lot of people who can't wait
to see you in the MCU what does joining
the MCU mean to you personally but also
what kind of in influence do you want to
have on that franchise that's a great
question I think
I was talking about this yesterday
actually I think as trans people you're
kind of
I mean growing up I didn't get to see
myself anywhere so I didn't really know
that I existed and especially not as a
in a superhero show or movie I think um
and so I think I just feel
deeply grateful and moved that um
little trans kids and trans teens have
something to look at and to know they
exist and to know that you know they can
have superpowers and that you know like
that's where we belong we don't just
belong in trauma stories on the fringes
dying in things you know like we we
belong there with the big guys so yeah
it meant a lot to me I cannot wait to
see I cannot wait to see everything all
of you do in the future but in the
meantime I will watch and re-watch this
movie I am obsessed with the idea your
performances are incredible I can't say
enough good things about talk to me
congratulations thanks so much thank you